What’s the key to living a happy, fulfilling
life?
Easy - just lower your expectations!
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and despite
all of the scientific advancements we’ve
made over the past few centuries - we still
haven’t figured out the formula for living
a happy life.
Common sense says that if we’re unhappy
with our current situation, then we should
change it - we can change our careers, change
our partners, change our friends.
But maybe we’re looking in the wrong place.
Maybe, the problem isn’t our surroundings
- it’s us.
And that’s exactly what a new study says
is true.
A team of researchers at University College
London have created a formula to predict happiness
levels, and according to them - being happy
in life isn’t about how things are “going”
for us, it’s about whether or not they’re
going “better than expected.”
Which means if we’re not happy, all we need
to do is change our expectations.
Specifically, we should lower them.
For their study, they invited 26 people to
play a gambling game, where they could choose
to either receive 40p for each game, or take
a gamble - and receive either 90p or nothing
at all.
During the experiment, they were repeatedly
asked to answer the question 'how happy are
you right now?'
while undergoing fMRI, to see if self-reported
happiness was related to rewards and expectations.
Researchers developed a model based on that
data, and used it to create a smartphone app
- where they repeated the experiment on over
18,000 participants.
What they found, is that accumulating wealth
didn’t make people happier, but the expectation
of wealth, did - and especially if people
weren’t expecting to win big.
It makes sense that this would be true, since
lower expectations make it more likely that
a given outcome will exceed those expectations.
But what’s interesting, is that positive
expectations can also influence happiness
before we’re even aware of the outcome.
The example they give, is meeting up with
a friend at a restaurant.
If it’s a restaurant you happen to know
and like, then the simple act of making those
plans could increase your happiness.
But they can also make you more unhappy down
the line - because your expectations are so
high, that it really wouldn’t take much
for you to be disappointed.
Granted, this is all relative - but it’s
a good reminder that we should keep our expectations
in check.
Assuming it’ll make you happier in the long
run, then what have you got to lose?
I think MadTV may have been onto something….
What do you guys think?
Is lowering your expectations as easy as they
make it seem?
Let us know your thoughts in the comments
below - and as always, thank you guys for
watching!